I just wanted to say that some uh I
think Jody is going to be amazing and
spoke to her the other day and she's so
full of excitement and so full of
passion about the show she really loves
the show and she's a brilliant actress
so it's really thrilling to know that
it's in the hands of somebody who who
cares for it so deeply and it's going to
do really really exciting things with it
which is a great choice well as I
mentioned yes I agree and I don't know I
feel I just feel I don't know why they
it's a bit tokenistic to cast a human as
the doctor no we're making progress you
know we're making progress or make of it
I could I just say something as well I
just wanted because I'm sure a lot of
people miss remar feeling exactly as I
do there is um I so many press articles
about a backlash among Doctor Who fandom
against the casting of a female doctor
there has been no backlash at all you
know the story of the moment is that is
that the notionally conservative Doctor
Who fandom is utterly embraced that
change completely 80% approval on social
media not that I check these things
obsessively
and yet so many people wanting to
pretend there's a problem there isn't in
fact it strikes me the Doctor Who fans
are more excited about the idea of a
brilliant actress playing the part than
the fact she's a woman it's been
incredibly progressive and enlightened
and that's what's really happened I wish
every single journalist who is writing
the alternative would shut the hell up
it's not true oh yeah
also if you call yourself a fan of
Doctor Who you buy innately couldn't be
upset by that because time lords can
regenerate in anything goes
you're an [ __ ] if you but you're not
a real fan of the show if you don't
accept this it is 100% with it you mean
it like everything about it